the inherent problem with Scientology is
not its simple beliefs about the
reactive mind or zenu or anything it is
the fact that it is an organization that
has a dedicated arm and branch
that only works on destroying people
they don't like and seeking to destroy
people they don't like and spends
tax-free tax-exempt money on doing so
that is what's wrong and that's what has
to be ended let me push back again yeah
go ahead so here's uh my pushback so if
somebody may say uh again the question
I'm trying to find out is what do they
see themselves at is it a religion is it
a government is it a country what do
they view themselves as because they
make somebody on the inside there may
say what are you talking about the
government's been doing this for the
longest time a political party just
targets one political side and just goes
and writes them constantly what is the
difference between what the government
gets to do versus what I'm able to do
and if somebody wants to come after us
we're going to go after them the mob did
this the government does this churches
don't do this sports teams do it Media
company do it you know somebody that
leaves one place to States when a talent
leaves to another place they're going
demonize this person of how bad of a
person they are and hey keep Tesla spots
open in Northern California if you don't
I'm going to move to Austin screw you
I'm moving to Austin let's demonize who
Elon Musk is what a bad person he is
what a bad terrible this is very normal
in it and when I tell you normal I don't
mean it that it's healthy all I mean it
is the fact that a lot of other
organizations use these manipulative
tactics to do that but here's a question
the question I got is does miscavige
does the Church of Scientology view them
as a country
do they view them as a themselves as a
church do they view themselves as a you
know their own Society a secret society
how do they really view themselves
because the way they viewed themselves
will dictate why they're making the
moves that they're making
they view themselves as a they view
themselves as a bubble a world of
Scientology that is
um the only place that has all of the
answers and that everything outside of
that world is uninformed or ignorant or
evil
and that ultimately Scientology must
take over the rest of
Society the rest of the world in order
to save it from itself and you're going
to say Patrick yep that's no different
than the fundamentalist Westborough
Baptist people or the this and that's
true it's not it's not different than
that but they pretend that that's not
the case but the truth of the matter is
Scientology wants to take over the
governments of all the World Hubbard
said the objective of the office of
special Affairs is to bring the
governments and societies of the world
into complete compliance with the aims
and policies of Scientology they want to
be
everything they they don't just want to
be the city of Clearwater or control the
city of Clearwater or they you think
they want to be everything like
worldwide but is it yes absolutely but
the membership has been declining though
membership isn't growing out what they
want and what they they tell themselves
they're accomplishing and what reality
is is two very different things right I
mean they you will hear scientologists
say we're changing the world we're
bringing education to the countries of
South America we're doing this we're
saving people here we're saving people
there and it's the internal [ __ ] PR
that they are fed propaganda of we found
a guy in you know Zimbabwe who said blah
blah and that gets translated into the
internal pitch that we've got Hubbard
Tech in all schools in Zimbabwe
and scientologists buy that [ __ ] you
know who you know where this now takes
me to
uh uh where this now takes me to is
any church you know ought to encourage
debate right any anybody any political
any family ought to encourage your kids
to debate right go debate and find a
better argument than the one I got
science is supposed to be debate
everything's supposed to be debate right
who's the person two and a half years
ago in the last two and a half years
that has encouraged people that you can
debate scientists anymore because it's a
fact who's that guy what's the guy's
name fouchie right some similarity
between fauci and miscavige on where you
were going with the whole uh you know uh
height situation but but fauci fauci is
a guy that is also driven by power
eventually it was my way or the highway
you don't question signs therefore you
don't question me right but this is
America that doesn't work Americans are
ones that like to question and they want
to have the freedom of speech to say
well I don't know about this and I don't
know about that and I don't know about
this in a moment people in America were
silenced if they disagreed that didn't
sit well with a lot of Americans because
that's in our DNA so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign